and now ladies and gentlemen we come to
one of the dramatic highlights of
modern-day entertainment time now to
pause for identification folks this is
television ladies and gentlemen miss
Olivia de Havilland the fabulous world
of motion pictures so wonderfully
represented tonight is always just
around the corner at your local theater
grape stars on those big screens bring
you laughter tears high adventure they
are all yours when you walk inside the
doors of your local theater so why
aren't you at the movies to present the
Foreign Language Film Award we have a
distinguished gentleman who represents
the American motion picture industry and
negotiations throughout the world
he recently concluded the most favorable
deal ever negotiated with the Russians
since I settle my bill at Romanovs
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Motion Picture Association mr. Eric
Johnson
as the world goes the human family is a
recent political idea put into effect
only three or four thousand years ago
some of the more optimistic among us
feel that we are a happy throng devoted
to merriment and good works now most of
us realize that this isn't quite true as
a matter of fact the human race is a
scattered and contentious one it is a
simple fact that we must all understand
that we are not automatically just going
to do the right thing we've got a long
long ways to go and it's going to be
very difficult for us to understand each
other we used to understand through the
library in the spoken word but now we
have the motion picture and motion
pictures are made everywhere and they're
shown everywhere we have sat on new
hearts and we have looked across and
seen the far shore we've learned to
laugh in another language we have been
taught to the uses of compassion all
these things are good and all these
things are represented in tonight's
Foreign Language Film Awards and
nominations from France black Orpheus
Sascha Gordon producer from Germany the
bridge Hermann Schwerin producer from
Italy the Great War Dino De Laurentiis
producer from Norway or from Denmark
Paul Moen Scott Hanson the producer from
the Netherlands the village on the river
from starvin Bernstein producer the
winner is oh it's black Orpheus
sweet resume seal Academy posted
distinction satin air who know the thule
gamma hot lava he knows - ready mercy he
posted said formidable I said surely
would thank you that's very nice what he
said was I did it all myself
thank you Eric Johnson is our ambassador
who does a great job you know a lot of
our actors have started making pictures
overseas the idea is to increase their
take-home pay without having to go home
and the idea is really catching on
last week my Japanese gardener told me
I'd have to pay him through a Swiss
corporation